with Steve Maxwell on the dish
this is the thief here now we're gonna
give you the breakdown hoist Gracie and
the Frank Shamrock he wants three I was
there for the first two yeah voices
conditioning coach for this first new F
state I know his game really well the
guy's amazing master of jujitsu
so let's break it down first of all this
whole hubbub about the needs of the
groin in those first fights groin shots
were allowed everybody knows from the
time they're a little kid how to protect
the groin so don't be crying about groin
shots kid they were ended what we called
the universal class we both have the
same basically position to each other
over under and they were both were
trying to throw the knees it did look
like the one knee hit when it went that
when the knee hit it look like can kind
of crumble a little bit simply back heel
take down from this position place
quickly did the match and then it was
all over after that
so congratulations where's Gracie he
showed us how powerful Gracie jiu-jitsu
is basic goods you just say 101 fight
was over by like 30 seconds but hey
listen man classic classic Clint's
situation you protect the groin and no
crime can the original fights everything
is gone you wanted the rematch you got
Steve max ball out of these show
joy this is the danger back here on the
D show with Steve Maxwell training over
half a century centuries a hundred years
so over what 53 years you've been ears
you've been taking this thing seriously
yes I did yeah as a child I was being
bullied yeah I was I was kind of a shy
kid actually and my father saw the way
it was going he was a former Navy boxer
during World War two he was in the
Pacific and he was actually the
bantamweight the Pacific Fleet
bantamweight champ back back in the day
and he tried to teach my brother in high
boxing and I wasn't particularly good at
it but I would get really mad when my
brother would get the better of me and
of course I would clinch him and take
him down
my father said your nut blocks are
you're a wrestler yeah so that very next
season he literally made me do all four
wrestling yeah it was the greatest thing
that ever happened yeah give it give it
give us some advice now there's a lot of
different trends you've seen them come
and go you've seen fads
you know peak out and lose out and
you're you're you know what I like now
we talked about the doctors a little bit
also a nutrition and being humble you
know knowing that you know what we've
scratched the surface even a person's
been studying 200 years there's so much
to learn so much some people that's when
you get stuck when you think you know it
all then the arrogance creeps in right
you need to stay humble yeah so tell us
from your humble experiences now you
know someone who's been around the block
a few times you traveled the war you now
get into that and a little bit about the
bag and how much it weighs but uh
CrossFit you've heard of this I have so
let's talk about let's start from there
what do you think about this crowd
wanted to start and what is it it
started back in the early 2000 yeah I
might have started even in the late
nineties but I heard about it in the
early let's say one day I hear about
this I opened my gym about in 1999 as I
first heard about this and at the time I
thought it was kind of interesting you
know I like cross-training to an extent
you know I along with jiu-jitsu when I
get the chance
I always enjoyed a bit of running and
weight training obviously and when I get
the chance I like to swim and so forth
but I look at these as recreations
there's a big confusion between what
constitutes exercise and recreation
exercises a five-point definition it
increases should increase strength
increase endurance increase cardio
respiratory health increase mobility and
flexibility and prevent injuries and
most of these things that people are
doing are actually recreations not true
exercise so this confusion has filtered
into what people what I call competitive
exercise and that's CrossFit it's
basically a sport where you competing in
exercise but the problem is if I said
right now hey let's do some push-ups you
know and let's get a good workout you
and I would be using really good form
and going nice and slow high tension and
get a nice safe chest arm workout but if
I said to you hey man I bet you 20 bucks
I could do more than you of course we're
going to throw a form to the wind and
you're going to do anything in your
power just to get the extra reps this is
a mistake this is this is nothing the
true purpose of exercise exercise should
prevent injuries not caused it so
anybody listening out there if you're
getting hurt doing your exercise you
need to take a hard look at what you're
doing because you're not you know you're
not exercising properly exercise
prepares your body to do the things that
we like to do like running or cycling or
swimming or tennis golf or in our case
we like to get on that mat and throw
each other around a little bit the true
exercise is designed now in tough boy
sports you know you can't be playing
rugby and soccer and basketball and you
know some of these contact sports ice
hockey and wrestling and all that kind
of stuff a madman without expecting get
hurt you're going to get hurt it's not a
matter of if it's a matter of just when
but proper strength training should
lessen the chance of that happening and
that's where people want wrong so if you
look at the founder of CrossFit there's
Greg Glassman he's basically just a
really overweight virtually obese
individual who is crippled up do you
want to follow the work on an advice
from a guy like that it makes no sense
it's like going to a nutritionist and
the guys really fat kingler or a doctor
that's got a Coke machine pop machine
our smoking smoking and it's the one in
fact that many doctors are actually
addicted to painkillers and drugs so I
mean are these the people you want to
entrust your health to I think not I
think that you for me personally what's
sustainable over a lifetime you know a
lot of guys in jiu-jitsu trained like
there's no tomorrow
but you and I know there is a tomorrow
and you got to live with this body so
you need a sustainable training models
that you can stick with for life all my
mentors were were old men see I say like
if you're listening to the advice of a
trainer under the age of 60 he probably
doesn't really hasn't figured it out yet
maybe he has but you know 20 or 30 year
old has no clue what's going on these
are not people I would want to listen to
all my mentors were older I have master
La Gracie his brother Carlos Gracie
Nikolay amasau who created the thousand
moves to Heaven joint mobility routine
he was a guy that came up with this
amazing way of preparing her joints
using the Russian Slovak health system I
trained with his old guy in Beijing this
mr. Han who does is Chi Kong in five
animal Gong system these are the people
I went to I want to go to the guys have
been through to the other side they've
seen you know both sides of yes that I
can trust what they say because the
proof is in the pudding yeah America's
own Jack LaLanne he was a pretty good
person to model your life line Paul
Bragg another health pioneer yeah you
know these guys they got into their 80s
and 90s and we're still very spry very
healthy and so forth these are the
people that I go to for health advice
I'm not going to listen to the guy in
musclehead magazine or
you know men's health or whatever
they're like you know 30s and even in
the 40s you still you know you know a
lot of guys still they they just don't
know what it's like yeah tell me Steve
we'll make a even barter how's this you
share with me your five pillars and
there are over one point seven billion
people that also lived by some five
pillars I'll share with you these five
pillars well you know as we're gonna
start off you want to start out with the
five and I'll start off with these five
when I did the five pillars I got a huge
amount of downloads from the Middle East
yeah I'm thinking wonder why all of a
sudden I have such a good and then every
five pillars of course but when you
exercise you want a good balance yeah
these are your five pillars yeah my five
pillars like a push and a pull right
both horizontal plane and the vertical
plane for every push you do overhead you
should do a pull for every push chest
press or push up you do you should do a
sub type of rowing movement body weight
well when I say row I'm gonna talk about
a rowing machine I'm talking about like
an actual strength boat then you have
your squat for your thighs and your hips
and then you have a hinging movement
where you're you're bending forward at
the waist like like a deadlift at
movement and then there's rotation and
anti rotation and there's another
subcategory called ancillary movements
where you want to work your fingers your
grip your forearms your wrists
obviously the neck and our sport the
next very important any type of contact
sport you want to make sure you work
that neck and the feet and the calves
are very neglected you want to work the
toes the feet so many guys in jiu-jitsu
and MMA break their toes and hurt their
feet so you got to keep the toes and the
feet very very strong and obviously the
calves yeah
and when those feet are weak by the way
there's a whole cascade of stress that
goes into the knees the hips and the
lower back sometimes union of the
shoulder these injuries are often the
result of very weak feet ankles and
calves is this still this is what this
is all all of them you yeah that was the
five pillars of exercise repeat and once
again okay so there's pushing and
pulling pushing and pulling okay both
horizontal
a vertical and horizontal yeah then
there's the squat then the squat some
type of squatting which it includes of
lunging okay in all its variations and
then there's hinging write it down guys
now right number three does that's
basically you know maximum hip movement
mimic the shins stay vertical okay
I'd like a kettlebell swing like a
Romanian deadlift or something like that
and then there's rotation and anti
rotation that'd be like you're planking
movement side plank you know where
you're forced to use your core for
stability and so forth then there's a
subset now this is five yeah well that
the rotation anti rotation is number
five Frye okay then there's a subset
yeah I call ancillary movements or
supplementary movements fingers hands
wrists forearms toes feet ankles and
calves yeah neck and sometimes some
isolation movements for the abdominals
getting quite effective beautiful that's
the five yeah can I share with you are
sure but this is amazing because when I
heard the five pillars I thought wow
this is something people live by you
know all across the world no matter if
you're from Poland from Italy from
Ireland you know it's it's the five
pillars the the one is the belief goes
back to spirituality what you talk about
about purpose really wanting to seek
purpose no purpose and and living by the
belief that there's only one creator one
God one deity nothing worthy of worship
except the one who created this whole
universe and everything in it praying
five times a day minimum paying the poor
do for tax to charity to poor people
fasting during Ramadan and one
pilgrimage to the first house of worship
built by Abraham this is called Hajj
that's the five pillars we got an even
exchange that man will take a brace as
like a good good way to base your life
yeah we're gonna take a break and we're
gonna talk about the bag before we
conclude I still wanna know how much it
weighs here on the Dean show with Steve
Maxwell women's rights
misconception women have no rights
the image of a woman wearing a veil from
head to toe a woman who gets unfair
justice or a woman who is not allowed to
drive is an all-too-familiar notion when
it comes to women treatment in Islam and
while there are Muslim countries in the
world that do implement many harsh
rulings against women this should not be
portrayed as Islamic law many of these
countries have cultural differences that
go against the teachings of Islam it
should be noted that during pre-islamic
women were used for fornication only and
had no independence the birth of a
daughter and a family was considered
humiliating and the practice of female
infanticide was uncontrolled when Islam
came back to being verses in the Quran
condemned the practice of female
infanticide Islam gave back many human
rights to the women and Muhammad's was
even reported saying that women are the
twin halves of men a Muslim woman is
allowed to reject and accept any suitor
for marriage and has the right to seek
divorce
there was nothing in Islam that forbids
a Muslim woman from exiting her house
and is allowed to drive also in regards
to education
a woman is obligated to seek knowledge
and it is considered a sin if she
refuses
- by the sword misconception Islam was
spread by the sword historian delacey
O'Leary states history makes it clear
however that the legend of fanatical
Muslims sweeping through the world and
forcing Islam at the point of the sword
upon conquered races is one of the most
fantastically absurd myths that
historians have ever repeated there is
no record in history that shows people
forced by sword point to convert to
Islam when Islam spread through
countries they would set up private
churches and synagogues for the
non-muslims they were governing and
because of the good treatment they had
received they themselves would convert
if one considers the small number of
Muslims who initially spread Islam to
the West all the way from Spain and
Morocco into the East from India and
China one would realize that such a
small group of people cannot force
others to be members of a religion
against their will it is also
interesting to note that when the
Mongols invaded and conquered large
portions of the Islamic empire instead
of destroying the religion they adopted
it
one Islamic terrorism misconception
muslims are terrorists this is by far
the biggest misconception of islam given
unfairly by stereotyping and the public
image that the media gives has anyone
else noticed how when a specific group
of people attack another group of people
it is labeled as a hate crime but when a
Muslim opens fire on anybody it is
quickly regarded as terrorism many
political dictators and officials or
extremist groups use the name of Islam
as a strategy to garner followers and
attention when many of their practices
go against the true basis of Islam the
media has also portrayed Islam as a cult
or a club where if you join you become a
terrorist and that is now part of your
agenda however all over the world people
practice Islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life there are many
verses in the Quran that go against the
idea of terrorism some of these verses
include fight the way of Allah those
that fight you but do not transgress
limits for God does not love
transgressors this basically means do
not fight except in self-defense and
even in doing so do not go beyond
offense another verse states if they
seek peace then you seek peace which
means do not attack people for no reason
or kill innocent people there is nowhere
in Islam whether it be in the Koran or
the teachings of Muhammad that promotes
the killing of innocent people
subscribe right now back here on the DS
show with Steve Maxwell man who's
traveled the world and back he's on the
DS show how much does that that bag
weigh 12 kilograms about twelve point
three how many pounds is that what is 12
kilograms like 2.2 pounds - killer so
about 25 pounds so how you know what it
reminded me there's a prophetic saying a
hadith what we call it it says it says
be in this world as a traveler now when
I look at you this is a great example
for it's the concept of you're not going
to go ahead and build a house at the bus
stop
you're not going to go ahead and you
know when you rent a room at the hotel
you start designing and whatnot you're
there temporarily right against the
hoarding against you know just making
this this temporary life that we're
going to permit at home this is a
transition point see plant seeds of
goodness serve others being the service
of people you know live your purpose but
don't get attached to something that's
temporary and you got that counts of
down packed it's also important not to
get too attached this flesh ball you
know the guys with the big preening
getting muscles and so forth you know
the girls that are really arrogant and
and egocentric with the thing it's all
gonna go Botox this talks it's gonna go
man so no sense getting a superficial
and I have to tell you I went from a
very simple lifestyle to where I owned a
gym two floors filled with equipment you
know four-story brownstone house in two
cars TV in every room and so forth but I
wasn't particularly happy I was very
stressed to tell the truth and once I
rid myself of all my earthly possessions
and took to this nomadic lifestyle it
was never so liberating you're free in
all my life and I basically have one
Thanh Binh 45 litre travel bag it's
about this wide by that high and I'd
like to wear it on my back when you
travel like I do roller bags or
terrible you know changing trains going
up and down stairs cobblestone streets
in some cases you know like snow or ice
you don't want to roller bag it's better
to carry on your body and I also like to
feel the weight of my possessions you
know I like to literally feel the weight
of my body and I have like a little man
purse with my cords my iPad and a couple
you know papers and stuff that's it and
I've been doing this for a while and
every couple weeks I'm in a new country
in a new place I get a chance to see the
entire world I'm not stuck like just in
one little town or one little area and
all I know is like tunnel vision yeah I
get to enact with people all over many
cultures and diversity so you get a much
more global view of the world and what's
going on yeah I like what you said that
my existence wasn't to make money you
mentioned something about me not being
bought or sponsored can you elaborate
elaborate on that I I have no sponsors
of my youtube page I've had many people
try nothing on my website
I'm not against making money we all need
money to survive I'm not gonna sell my
soul for the almighty dollar no way I
feel like you know if I start allowing
some of these advertisers that I don't
necessarily use or believe in that's
selling out so anything that you'll see
in steve maxwell site or whatever are
things that I actually use myself I
think I basically think is the sin to to
start being a hypocrite yeah you know
started espousing things just to make
the money yeah I didn't want to do that
I wanted to say is pure to my ideals as
I could you know so I mean that was the
the idea behind it so I very strict
about what I allow on the website and
what I don't
and yes I need money you know to live
but I don't live for money yeah money is
just how many people got it but at the
end they're miserable right there's more
to life
it's like people that live to eat yeah
you know instead of you know eating to
eating to live yeah well it's the same
thing with money some people just you
know it's all about accumulation and
storing and and hoarding and gaining but
that's not what we're here for that's at
least in my belief system that you know
that's how many it is a consequence of
what I do not why I do have this world
in your hand not in your heart
exactly yeah we're out of time and I
know you packed light here's a gift you
can't come onto dish and I'll get a gift
thank you I will definitely put this
little bag to thank you so much God
bless you God thank you thank you for
being with us here on the Dean show we
look forward to when you're in town you
got a home here visit again and visit
work with people look you up now if they
want to contact you Maxwell SC comm wws
as in strength C is conditioning SC comm
lots of really cool video downloads
stuff that I believe it and also a whole
list of all my seminars coming up I'm
doing a Gracie jiu-jitsu
for a lifetime training camp in Maui
this next spring you got to you got to
come paint gonna be with Louisa Reiter
at Maui just said it's gonna be
unbelievable while trying to get thank
you so much for being with us thank you
Steve thanks for having me subscribe
right now
you